so I'm going to start off with four job
in work jobs which is giving me the jobs
array in the work object then I'm going
to append HTML work start to the work
experience div which we can see right
here in our HTML then I'm gonna work on
formatting the employer in the title to
do so I'll use the HTML work employer
and HTML work title strings that are in
Halper a is calling the replace method
on both of them
I will replace the placeholder data with
our employer and our title from the work
dot jobs object notice here that I'm
using job the iterator from the for in
loop as the index of the job that we
want inside the work dot jobs object
this variable formatted employer title
is a concatenation of formatted employer
and formatted title we're just adding
them together this last line here
appends the formatted employer title
which we just created to work entry last
now this is an interesting syntax in
jquery we're selecting every object with
the class work entry we know we want a
class because it has a dot in front of
it but then this colon last tells us
that we specifically want to append this
formatted employer title to the last
element with the class work entry on the
page which should be the one we just
created let's go ahead and check our
work we've refreshed the page and we can
see that within the work experience
section we can see our two entries for
work experience for Planet Express and
finuccis pizza and it looks good too